and so they're off to Pleasure Island
dark place and the coachman opens the
gates and lets the delinquents into
Pleasure Island and they basically have
a riot and this is Pleasure Island here
it's full of amusement park rides and
you know one of the things that's kind
of interesting about horror movies I'm
sure you've noticed this is that they're
often sat at amusement parks and clowns
are often characters of horror will
leave the clown's aside for now but the
amusement park thing that's pretty
interesting it's like why in the world
with an amusement park be a place of
horror and the first question might be
well have you ever been to an amusement
park because there is something about
them that's really they have a dark side
a clear dark side and part of it is that
people with nothing better to do are
spending money stupidly and they're
being fleeced by the people who operate
the the amusement park you know when
they have let's say a stereotypically
dark reputation and they're moving
around all the time this is also
something that Psychopaths do and all
they're doing is moving from community
to community and taking the money from
the rubes fundamentally and so the
amusement park well if you walk through
an amusement park with that sort of
thing in mind maybe that's also coloring
your vision of course but it's something
that you can see very immediately so
there's something about them that's sort
of deeply sad but there's also that
under there's an underlying horror that
characterizes them that it's easy for
horror movie and/or horror novel writers
to immediately expand upon and there's
something about it that that makes sense
to people
so to easy
maybe that's and it's also all
short-term gratification that's the
other thing so you spend your money very
rapidly and it's gone yep so a big what
a celebration of meaning the work design
yeah yes exactly well that's the
impulsive element that the comment was
it's a celebration of of meanings
divorced from reality yeah
well it's also outside of reality right
that's why it's on an island it's a
separate universe and it's a universe
where nothing that's happening is
connected to anything outside and you're
spending your hard-earned money let's
say but it isn't that much it's
certainly not an investment it's not
that much different than burning it what
is because of course you get some
pleasure out of it but but it isn't
going there every day is probably not
the wisest move that you could make so
the animators do a good job of well of
presenting the what would you call it
the enforced hedonism I guess I would
say of a place like that this is a place
where you're going to have fun that's
what it's for